et pour en parler nous sommes avec
guillaume bigot politologue ancien
conseiller de jean-pierre chevènement
bonsoir guillaume bigot
que vous inspire cette polémique en
pleine pandémie n'est ce pas un petit
peu tiré par les cheveux tout de même on
a du mal parfois avoir le rapport entre
masqué voile c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment qu'elle veut dire c'est tiré
par les cheveux
en fait cette envie peut-être plus long
sur les etats-unis et leurs intentions
et leurs cultures politiques d'ailleurs
que sur nous je m'explique c'est à dire
que on voit bien quand même que cette
polémique n'aurait pas pu naître
ailleurs que dans un an dans une dans un
cerveau d'anglo-saxons protestants blond
c'est vraiment la mentalité typique des
wasps c'est à dire qu'il y a une
extraordinaire tolérance
en apparence il ya une une vision de la
liberté en partie de la liberté
religieuse qui est extrêmement large
extensible et simultanément
ce sont des pays il n'y a pas des états
unis ce sont des pays dans lesquels il
n'ya quasiment on peut dire aucune forme
de mixité
en fait ces sont des pays qui insistent
sur la très grande liberté d'expression
aux états unis tous les racismes ont
pignon sur rue le ku klux klan la nation
de l'islam et les chaînes de télévision
nazis dont on peut raconter à peu près
tout et n'importe quoi c'était le cas
aussi en grande bretagne et il ya une
entourent l'islamisme le plus radical
d'une extraordinaire tolérance on le
protège l'extraordinaire tolérance mais
simultanément vous n'avez quasiment pas
de mariages mixtes
certains britanniques ne va jamais se
marier avec une pakistanaise
un lecteur du washington post n'ira pas
se marier non plus avec une mine
yéménite
donc ça en dit long d'une certaine façon
sur la société américaine
peut-être aussi peut-on sans verser dans
la paranoïa se dire que il y a une
stratégie américaine parce que ils
savent bien ils sont très bien placés
pour savoir que l'islamisme est très
dangereux
leurs armes et ont eu l'affronter de
près en irak en afghanistan mais qu'en
réalité a poussé l'islamisme dans les
banlieues
sans les bons les françaises finalement
on affaiblit un état nation comme la
france
est-ce que ça rentre dans la stratégie
décrite par par exemple un joseph brésil
ce qui dans le grand échiquier un des
grands stratèges américains c'est à dire
qu'il faut affaiblir y compris les pays
alliés pour maintenir d'une certaine
façon les jeunes américains la
domination et la superpuissance
américaine c'est une question alors
selon nos confrères mariana les experts
cités dans cet article du washington
post serait orientée pour accréditer
donc leur thèse
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
crédible c'est pas la première fois il y
a déjà eu l'intervention du département
d'état qui a soutenu des associations
indigéniste des associations d'ailleurs
proche des frères musulmans dont les
banlieues françaises
il ya eu des financements également par
des associations privées ou des
entreprises qui étaient probablement
instrumentalisé par le département
d'état américain
donc ce n'est pas la première fois en
réalité un que ça se produit donc il ya
ça rentre si vous voulez dans cette
stratégie qui est une stratégie
d'influencé des états unis qui vise
finalement soit à promouvoir un
dépassement du cadre d'états nations
pour favoriser l'avènement d'un état
européen d'un état supranational et une
certaine façon il faut que les nations
meurt avec leurs spécificités tombe pour
que l'europe puisse naître mais c'est
aussi peut-être une stratégie
d'affaiblissement tout simplement d'un
acteur qui est en rivalité souvenez vous
de ce que disait françois mitterrand en
apparence entre les états unis et la
france
il n'y a pas il ya un état de paix
apparent mais en fait c'est une guerre
qui en apparence est une guerre
d'influencé une guerre culturelle une
guerre de soft power et qui en apparence
ne fait pas de morts il faisait allusion
au fait que la rivalité notamment sur le
continent africain entre les deux
puissances américaines et françaises est
redoutable
merci guillaume bigot nous avoir apporté
votre analyse sur ce sujet merci à vous
aurez en